but on the library alexander let me ask
uh be because you were on joe rogan
it does make me really sad and i realize
that i'm just probably being romantic
that
his most of his library of
interviews that were on youtube have now
been taken down
because he went to spotify and that was
the first i'm probably an idiot but
it was the first time i realized that
this knowledge that we've been
building up on the internet doesn't
necessarily last forever
no it doesn't unless you preserve it i
mean it's like all things
if if you do not preserve them if you do
not make
uh efforts um you know so many of my
it just really brings to minor off the
top of my head all my so many friends of
of mine that are jewish uh you know
they're they're basically secular
but yet through even the secular
aspect of just keeping the traditions
alive it's like well you could always
pick a book and read out about read
about it clearly
it's called the torah but um
if you don't put these things into
action if you don't make them a part of
your consciousness maybe even on the
subconsciousness just by through through
repetition they will die and they will
become
simply something that exists somewhere
until you
find it again and carl gotch used to say
something um
he would say that i don't invent moves i
just rediscover them
but yet gotch and billy robinson also
would understand that
you if someone's not carrying the torch
it'll go out now that doesn't mean fire
can't be rekindled it just means that it
that torch no longer is lighting the way
on on this knowledge and so it's it's
important to
be an individual even on an individual
level to be a repository for
for aspects of knowledge
you